have you given uh 69 any
off camera off clubhouse advice because
it i feel like i told him we should stop
disrespecting the dead
you know what i told him that
you didn't made enough enemies
but you give some of that attention to
your fans
i i don't think that
you need to be so uh controversial
on the negative side
to
bring attention to your music i think
it's
i've seen him do things you know like
over the years but i don't even know who
he was you know i've seen him like go
visit uh
go and visit uh
uh
kids you know what i mean that on a last
leg of living and stuff like that so i
feel like you know if you're gonna do
something man focus on your music and do
some positive things man you know your
fans let your fans love you people
that's gonna hate you that's they gonna
hate you you've done what you did
there's no sense in uh antagonizing them
any more
you know especially the little dirk [ __ ]
you know i like little dirk yeah the
dirt [ __ ] i feel like he's out of pocket
no i like i like little dirt you know
what i mean so
you know i think love dirk had made a
verse or something on some drake song
you know i don't know or some [ __ ] but
so what it's a verse you know what i
mean the [ __ ] you know i mean i i i like
little dirt you know what i mean so um
you know anybody tired a little dirt you
know he need to refrain from saying the
things he's been saying you know this
that's what i told him you know what i
mean so whether he does it looked at me
like he might be doing it but you never
yes his own man